Michelle I understand that you attended
acting classes in New York City was it
back when you were 18 or so what did you
see in your teachers then that you
wanted to emulate your students now and
also vice versa what did you see that
maybe didn't work that you wanted to
make sure that you provided for your
students well yes in the late 70s and in
the 80s I was running around New York
City studying and luckily enough
studying with Stella Adler and with Rue
de Hagen and Herbert Bergdorf and Bill
Esper and just a slew of wonderful
teachers I think it was really
fascinated by the craft of acting and
what made you know a great acting
performance and so I learned from the
great icons and yes Stella was very
passionate and it was very passionate
and that you need to have that kind of
passion to fire up you know a young
generation of actors and conversely what
did you see that maybe you wanted to
make sure that you always provided your
students that sometimes maybe other
teachers didn't a certain way of talking
to them because I took so many acting
classes and saw so many different styles
of teachers
one of the things that always made me
run were teachers there were mean and
and there were several of them you know
this this old cliche that if you tear an
actor down and then you build them up
again they learn something maybe a
profound truth about themselves or a way
of acting that just is deeper and I
never quite could sign up for that kind
of you know massacre so I didn't I never
wanted to teach like that I never wanted
to make a student's run out of the room
run out of the theater and cry
and feel defeated so you know though I
mean Stella Adler was she was very
entertaining and she was tough I think
there's a difference between being
challenging and but that's constructive
then being you know tough and really
putting a student down which is
destructive and that's what I think of
the main lessons that I learned
you